which function has no x-intercepts so an
x-intercept is a place where the
function intersects the x-axis and what
do we know about what's going on when
something is on the x-axis well if
something is on the x-axis then you
could say the y-value is zero or if y is
equal to the function you would say that
the value of the function is zero you
have an x-intercept whenever the
function itself is equal to zero so
essentially this is equivalent to saying
which function never equals zero so
let's see with if any of these functions
never equal zero so let's look at this
first function right over here and let
me write it right over here so I have f
of X is equal to x squared plus 5 so
this is interesting x squared is always
going to be a non-negative number it'll
be 0 or greater even if X is a negative
value this is going to be 0 or greater
and 5 is obviously positive so this
value this whole value or this whole
expression x squared plus 5 is always
going to be greater than or equal to 5
so we could say f of X is always going
to be greater than or equal to 5 so f of
X is never going to be equal to 0
if you don't believe me let's try it out
another way let's set f of X equals 0
and figure out what which X that might
be true so though we could say 0 is
equal to x squared plus 5 subtract 5
from both sides you would get negative 5
is equal to x squared and if you take
the principal root of both sides you get
the principal root of negative 5 is
equal to X you could even have the
positive and negative principal root of
negative 5 but needless to say unless
you're dealing with if you're dealing
just with real numbers there is no real
number that is a square that is the
square root of negative 5
so f of X has no x-intercepts so this
right over here it meets the criterion
this right over here has no x-intercepts
let's see if these other ones have
x-intercepts so remember you have an
x-intercept if the value of the function
is 0 at some point and we see right over
here
this function G of X is really defined
with this table and we see it does
indeed equal zero it happens to equal
zero when x equals zero so it intersects
the x-axis right over there that's its
x-intercept now let's look at this green
function H of X where does that
intersect the x-axis well that's
visually more obvious it intersects the
x-axis right over here H of X is zero
when X is equal to negative six so these
last two functions have x-intercepts
this first one does not